so we have a great talk tonight miles
Traer is is a Stanford geoscientist he
this is actually his second appearance
here at the interval I don't know if
anyone was here for our heroic and
Arctic event that we had all right last
year was a collaboration with the folks
at odd salon our good friends I think we
got a couple odd salon folks here
tonight yes
I just they're gonna be noisy tonight
but it's a good thing they're there
they're another great local speaking
series and actually would encourage you
to check them out as well and Myles is
also the co-founder of the generate
generation and thrombus e'en podcast and
we'll well we'll talk to him a little
bit that hopefully in QA well we'll talk
a little bit about that and about the
geology of the game of thrones world and
some other fantastic things that he does
with his science skills so so so we have
that to look forward to but but right
now we're gonna start right here and and
deep below where we are right now the
geologic reveal begins now we're on folk
laws for miles fair
hello Mic Check Mic Check yay thanks for
the intro Michael and thanks to the
interval for having me here
very excited maíam miles Traer I am a
geological data scientist at Stanford
University and tonight I wanted to talk
with you about the geological reveal
there's a natural language embedded in
our planet and it's a beautiful language
it's a language of ecology it's a
language of climate change it's a
language of natural disasters of
earthquakes and volcanoes it's a
language of biology evolution and humans
we learn how to read this language so
that we can decipher the relationships
between these staggeringly complex
systems in fact these systems are often
so complex that the language often
sounds like my job is to translate that
and to make that translation I use the
tools of data science computational
physics and geology specifically I look
at planetary surface evolution and the
fancy name for what I do is called
computational geomorphology it basically
says that I study the physical processes
that create and transform the land
surface I then take those processes and
translate them into the language of
physics this is what modern geology
looks like the processes that I study
can be tectonic they can be huge forces
that slam continents together and rip
them apart they can be rivers that
slowly erode down the mountains formed
in those continental collisions and
transport sediment from the highlands to
the lowlands and deposited all places in
between or those processes can
increasingly be us humans who today
dig up and transport more sand rock and
dirt than all of the world's rivers
combined if that last fact didn't make
it clear we have a complicated
relationship with the natural world it's
one that's gone back a long long time
but even that word relationship which I
realize I used in the title of my talk
that word relationship is problematic
it's a little bit misleading we don't
have a relationship with the natural
world that would somehow imply that
we're separate from the natural world
and were not otherwise we wouldn't be
able to read our history in the rock
record this is exactly why future
geologists will be able to dig back
through the rock layers and read our
relationship with the natural world
today so that's what I wanted to do
tonight is take a look at that natural
relationship and I thought I'd focus in
on the Bay Area and I thought we'd do
that for two basic reasons one we're all
here we're in the Bay Area and two if I
tried to cover our relationship to the
planet we'd be here a while in fact we
might be here until the long now is ten
thousand year clock stop spinning so one
of the challenges in asking a
geoscientists to talk about the natural
history of the Bay Area is it to a
geoscientist pretty much everything is
natural history and that goes for
everything from contemporary climate
change to hundreds of millions of years
ago when all of the continents slammed
together to form the supercontinent of
pangaea to billions of years ago when
bacteria first learned how to
photosynthesize and first breathed
oxygen into our atmosphere to that
elongated moment four-and-a-half billion
years ago when a collection of dust and
debris slowly formed the ball that we
call earth so rather than start today
and just go back millions of years
I thought
try to focus in on some of the major
reasons Homo sapiens humans first came
to the Bay Area at all and eventually
built San Francisco and I'll suggest
that all of those reasons oh themselves
to geology so here are my greatly
oversimplified reasons humans first came
to the Bay Area one there was a ton of
stuff to eat too
the bay was a natural Harbor that
provided sanctuary from the elements and
three gold so let's start with that
first one the historian Alfred Crosby
wrote it is crudely true that if man's
caloric intake is sufficient he will
somehow stagger to maturity and he will
reproduce or as I've paraphrased that if
bacon then sexytime
so what was there for the first humans
to eat where were they getting their
calories from well chances are whatever
they were eating it wasn't coming from
trees and that's because before the
Europeans showed up and brought all of
their trees with them the peninsula
looked like this it was covered in huge
sand dunes that the sand dunes that
Broome cells were covered in shrubs and
grasses in these beautiful wildflowers
and there were a couple of native trees
there were oak trees and the California
Buckeye but the acorns from the oak
trees weren't particularly delicious or
nutritious unless you ground them up and
cooked them for a really long time and
the seeds from the California Buckeye
were toxic so I think it's safe to say
their calories were coming from
elsewhere among the larger animals that
hung out on the peninsula were deer and
they were delicious but they also tended
to hang out with you know bears and
mountain lions which meant that human
hunters had to compete with several
hundred pounds of claws and teeth than
ah so that got kind of dicey but
fortunately for humans there was seafood
and seafood had two distinct advantages
over dealing with the Bears and the
mountain lions
it was a abundant and be far less likely
to eat you nestled into the shoreline
were all of these bays and salt marshes
that we can read in previous maps are
digging down through the bay muds and
these bays and salt marshes were home to
countless different kinds of shellfish
and regular fish which themselves
attracted all sorts of huge birds and
adorable sea otters with their tendency
of holding hands while they sleep so
they don't float away there are also
millions of salmon that swam through the
bay and up to freshwater rivers to spawn
and if you remember those toxic
California Buckeye seeds early Native
American tribes would use
toxins to quote stupefy the fish unquote
which made catching them way easier so
why is it that so many different plants
and animals found such a comfortable
home here in the Bay Area well the
answer is of course geology
[Music]
so the Sierra Nevada mountains look I
have different labels from my Maps so
the Sierra Nevada mountains are to the
east of us and there are a lot of rivers
that drain off of those mountains into
the Central Valley and in California
something strange happens and that two
of the largest river systems the San
Joaquin in the south and the Sacramento
in the north hit the coast range and
converge most rivers as they approach
the ocean tend to splay out to these
giant fans and those fans themselves
will tend to jump from one location to
the next I have some experience
researching this and you can read that
changing pattern in the rock record but
here in California those two huge river
systems are funneled through a narrow
mile wide gap in the mountains the
Golden Gate San Francisco Bay is itself
a giant estuary that drains something
like 40% of all of the land in
California which means that us here in
the Bay Area we get a lot of
California's freshwater converging on
this geographically small area and
that's really important because
estuaries are basically the nurseries of
the natural world you get all of this
freshwater and saltwater mixing together
which creates this whole range of
environments for all of these different
species to thrive in
all of these species that we find tasty
so if it is crudely true that if man's
caloric intake is sufficient he will
somehow stagger to maturity and he will
reproduce then we owe a human presence
in the Bay Area to the estuary which
itself was created by the geology let's
move on to that second reason now and
let's fast-forward to Europeans
Europeans first came to the Bay Area
primarily because it was a natural
Harbor and our early maps of the
peninsula here showed that there were a
lot of smaller bays that were tucked
into the coastline where ships could
safely drop anchor
there was yerba buena Cove there was
Mission Bay and where we are right now
in the marina humans later filled in a
lot of those bays with sand and rubble
and debris often just to keep their
houses from sinking into the marsh but
where did those Bay's come from actually
before we get to that this red outline
that I'm showing here is the modern San
Francisco Bay shoreline and this map is
from I think the mid 1800s and so you
can see how dramatically we've already
affected the physical coastline how
dramatically we've already affected the
natural environment just in a hundred
and fifty years so where did that
original topography where did those
original bays come from and in fact
where did the bay come from well the
answer is of course geology but not in
the way you might think the presence of
the bay itself owes less to tectonic
forces and more to ice ages and that's
because for most of its existence the
San Francisco Bay was actually a dry
inland valley somewhere around 20,000
years ago earth was just about to leave
the last ice age and so much of Earth's
water was frozen into ice out at the
poles that sea level was way lower than
it is today
in fact the San Francisco shoreline
would have been about 30
to the west of us the Farallon Islands
which on a good clear day you can see
from San Francisco which are now a
Marine Sanctuary where you can swim with
great white sharks were once just hills
on a vast dry plain a river cut across
the slope exiting the Golden Gate and
entering the Pacific Ocean just south of
the farallon's and at this time you
could have walked from Oakland to San
Francisco without getting your feet wet
as you walked through that Inland Valley
you would have walked through groves of
redwood trees and would have had to
tiptoe past wooly mammoths we know this
because we found redwoods and mammoths
in the bay muds these are early
geologists by the way then around 18,000
years ago something happened climate
began to change things began to warm up
very slowly much slower than it is now
and as the climate began to warm sea
level began to rise sea level crept
inland and it crept all the way up to
the Golden Gate before it eventually
flooded the entire Inland Valley and
created modern San Francisco Bay around
6,000 years ago ever since that time the
shape of the bay has constantly
transformed partly due to sort of
natural erosion processes but also a lot
because of us we filled in a lot of
those smaller Bay's we've built islands
and we've totally changed the
sedimentation processes flowing into the
bay with agriculture in the Central
Valley we've dramatically changed the
shape of the bay and one of the most
dramatic changes actually started in the
California Gold Rush during the
California Gold Rush geologists estimate
that we dug up something like 8 times
the amount of sand and rock than we did
building the entire Panama
now and we dumped all of that sediment
into the rivers that sediment found its
way back to the Bay Area and that sand
and mud totally changed the coastline
but it wasn't just that one physical
change that we can read from the rock
record because mixed in with all of
those sands and muds were chemical
traces things like mercury that we use
to process the gold or the provide a
marker of how we were interacting with
the physical world at that time so the
gold rush had a huge impact on the Bay
Area and had a huge impact on our
relationship with the natural world and
of course speaking of the gold rush
let's talk about that gold so as I was
preparing this talk I began to write
down a description a 100% accurate
description of the geochemical process
of gold ore deposition and it's
important that you know that this is a
100% accurate description because it's
also inappropriate and I guarantee after
I'm done saying it you'll never look at
a geologist the same way gold is
typically erupted from deep beneath the
earth through narrow slits on the ocean
floor and then the dry continental crust
begins to grind up against the moist
oceanic crust and as the to grind up
against each other there's a lot of
friction and things get really hot and
then the gold melts and gets pushed deep
into thick veins of quartz that get up
lifted during the Sierra Nevada orogeny
and eventually become the California
lode
geology
let's leave Barry up there so the same
tectonic forces that deposit it created
and deposited the gold here in
California are also responsible for
creating most of California the Sierra
Nevada mountains popped up around 40 to
60 million years ago and at the time
everything to the west of them was
buried under a shallow ocean and also at
this time there was a smaller tectonic
plate called the Juan de Fuca plate that
was smashed in between the Pacific plate
and the North American continent and as
the Pacific plate and North American
continent began to collide in with each
other the Juan de Fuca plate got
smooshed underneath North America what
we call subduction and as it was
subducted the top layers of the plate
got scraped off and eventually accreted
onto the side of the North American
continent those huge forces the
continental collision also took that
Central Valley buried under the shallow
ocean and lifted it up above sea level
and eventually created the land that we
call California when you look at a
geologic map like this we'll see a lot
of very pretty colors and it's important
to note that those colors don't really
represent different types of rock they
represent layers of geologic time when
we read a geological map like this it's
a story of big events passing through
history and in this case a lot of that
history a lot of that natural history
happened before humans ever showed up on
the evolutionary tree but it's the same
forces that created the gold that
created the state itself to created the
fertile soil that ended up leading to
humans playing such a large role here in
the Bay Area so up until now when we've
read the rock rec
we've seen shallow oceans and we've seen
ancient tectonic plates we've travelled
from the ocean floor to dry inland
valleys to sand dunes to salt marshes
we've walked with woolly mammoths swam
with adorable yet Bastardly sea otters
and we've eaten the salmon stupefied by
the buckeyes seeds in short we've seen
San Francisco's nature change over
millions of years and most of those
changes have been physical and certainly
our imprint has been largely physical to
a geoscientist I often look for those
physical imprints because they're easy
to find not easy but easier but they're
not the only remnants that get left in
the rock record they're not the only
things that get left their ideas are
preserved in the rock record as well and
to see how our ideas end up in the rock
record we're gonna go from the gold rush
to 1906 in April of 1906 two events
transpired that forever changed the way
geoscientist viewed the earth we proved
the existence of ghosts using
photography and we found out that
lunatics do not in fact require toupees
these are both real so the reason I
wanted to start with these two examples
for 1906 was mostly jokes but also to
help us travel back in time to 1906 and
the types of scientific questions being
asked back then these two rather
ridiculous examples aside this was a
time when Harry Houdini was waging a
one-man war against seances and mystics
Nikola Tesla's alternating electric
current which all of you use in your
homes was brand-new and barely being
used in major cities for lighting and
gilma Marconi's long distance wireless
Telegraph was state-of-the-art
technology for sending messages and it
was very expensive and really only
available to social elites and it was in
this context that I wanted to explore
the 1906 earthquake and how our ideas
become embedded in the rock record what
did we know before the earthquake and
what did we learn in its aftermath well
in terms of 1906 it's actually much
easier to talk about what we learned in
the aftermath because before honestly we
didn't know that much keep in mind that
to a geoscientist in 1906 the theory of
plate tectonics the fundamental
mechanism by which we understand how the
planet works wouldn't be formally
accepted for another 60 years
the earthquake struck at 5:12 in the
morning on April 18th 1906 the fault
slipped 21 feet in a matter of seconds
and as it slipped it sent out waves of
energy earthquake waves that rippled out
into the surrounding areas
police sergeant Jesse Cooke was standing
on Davis Street in San Francisco and he
watched the ground
undulate beneath him and he later wrote
it was this it was as if the waves of
the ocean were coming toward me
billowing as they came Davis Street
split open right in front of me a gaping
trench about six feet deep and half full
of water suddenly yawned and sprang up
on the sidewalk at the southeast corner
while the walls of the building I had
marked from my Asylum began tottering
before I could get into the shelter of
the doorway the walls had actually
fallen in word but the stacked up cases
of produce that filled the place
prevented them from collapsing part of
what makes the 1906 earthquake so
important to a geoscientists like myself
is that so many people made observations
like this they noted the time and the
intensity of the shaking and they
documented the destruction using
photography which is a new concept in
documenting earthquakes in the years
that followed the earthquake a team of
researchers gathered together to study
the earthquake in greater detail than
had ever been done before and the team
of researchers was led by this stud of a
man the head of the geology department
at UC Berkeley go bears his name was
Andrew Lawson and Lawson and his
colleagues set out again to document the
earthquake in greater detail than had
ever been attempted before because they
had access to much more information a
lot more data so they began to conduct
interviews with the survivors they
documented the destruction themselves
taking photographs and they make
countless measurements around the Bay
Area and collected the own
ninety-two seismographic readings of the
earthquake
none of which came from the United
States so that was hard work in 1906 in
the end Lawson and his team produced a
report cleverly called the Lawson report
and it totally revolutionized the
burgeoning field of seismology it was
also a 400 page document that very few
people read but hidden in those pages
embedded in those changes were the seeds
of ideas that would ripple out and
become embedded in the rock record they
began by just making observations Lawson
and his colleagues noted that the
earthquake appeared to have started on
the San Andreas Fault and while that
might sound obvious today that wasn't
known back then in fact in 1906 most
people geologists included thought that
earthquakes and all of the shaking
created the fault rather than the fault
generating the earthquake Lawson and his
colleagues also noted that the fault had
slipped horizontally rather than
vertically and again while that seems
like sort of a trivial observation it
slipped horizontally at the time it was
thought that earthquakes could only be
generated by vertical motions so with
these two seemingly simple deceptively
simple observations the Lawson report is
already radically transforming our
understanding of the natural world and
our relationship with it Lawson also
teamed up with a man named Grove Karl
Gilbert who is a legend too nerdy
geologists like myself and Lawson and
Gilbert set out to map all 600 plus
miles of the San Andreas Fault through
California not an easy job in 1906 on
foot and horseback through a lot of
poison oak
but they ended up making that trace and
they ended up documenting again all of
these motions along the fault these
deceptively simple observations and
while those are very important perhaps
the most revolutionary concept to be
found in the Lawson report
belongs to this man a geologist from
Johns Hopkins University named Henry
Fielding Reed and Reed and his
colleagues came out to the Bay Area very
soon after the earthquake and they began
to make their own observations and
specifically they were interested in how
the landscape had changed
you know before and after the earthquake
and what Reed and his colleagues noted
is that the fault didn't appear to have
slipped the same amount every where in
fact they saw that it had slipped a much
greater distance where the earthquake
epicenter was and then as you moved away
from that epicenter along the San
Andreas Fault it seemed to slip less and
less and less and less as though the
crust itself were absorbing some of that
motion a little bit like a rubber band
just sort of elastically absorbing
something
this led Reid and his colleagues to
propose a new theory on the working
mechanics of earthquakes they postulated
that stress and strain would build up on
a fault over time a little bit like
stretching out that rubber band until
eventually the friction on the fault
could no longer hold and it would slip
and generate an earthquake the rubber
bands snapping back into place this
theory became known as elastic rebound
theory and to this day it is still the
best working hypothesis we have on the
fundamentals of earthquakes it's hard
for me to convey just how revolutionary
this report was and how important this
report was to geosciences everything we
take for granted has its origins here
the fact that we can drive down the
coast to Montara beach and if you walk
to the southern end of the beach nestled
into the cliff you'll see a shape that
looks like a V
in the rocks and next to it you'll see a
group of granite that doesn't belong
there because granite belongs under
mountain belts and there are no
mountains down there
well our knowledge that faults can slip
horizontally led us to figure out that
this granite came from Los Angeles and
was transported up here over millions of
years of horizontal motion on the faults
the fact that you can go out to a fence
that once crossed the San Andreas Fault
and in 1906 was offset by that near 20
feet and that all of us would look at
that without having me explained much of
this you would be able to look at that
and say oh yeah that was probably an
earthquake something slipped and that's
what created that sort of motion those
ideas that intuition began here and the
very idea that we have to pay for pretty
expensive retrofits for buildings also
began here we have to protect ourselves
from these earthquake waves in these
motions in 1906 this was a big deal and
this is how our ideas began to imprinted
a rock record we don't need to go
through all of this history in a book
anymore you can go out look at that
offset fence look at that v look at the
granite and be able to intuit ah
plate tectonics earthquakes natural
history is happening here so we're now
up to 1906 and I want to shift now to
the present day and we're gonna turn now
to Otto's beautiful drawing here what
Otto has drawn are the different
shorelines that existed in the Bay Area
going back 18,000 years all the way up
to the present and you can see the X is
us here at the interval and it's not
hard to imagine that if the shoreline
has changed this much that it's going to
continue to change and certainly as
humans play a bigger and bigger role in
transforming the landscape we've already
seen examples of that in fact the idea
of humans being a geological force
capable of transforming landscapes has a
name it's called the Anthropocene
and I have a podcast all about it you
can ask me about it the idea of the
Anthropocene is that humans are a
geologic force on par with plate
tectonics ice ages things of that nature
and the idea that we're going to add a
new chapter in the geologic time table
is a really big deal it's like adding a
new element to the periodic table so
this is a profound statement of who we
are and what we're capable of and given
that it's not hard to imagine at all
that a hundred years from now a thousand
years from now Otto would have to draw
some really weird contours up here but
again those are some of those physical
changes and our ideas what we want to
preserve and to end the talk I didn't
want to end in the modern day in the
Anthropocene I actually wanted to go
back in time once more and specifically
I wanted to go back to the Year 1795 an
Coover became the first Englishman to
ever set foot in San Francisco and he
his ship parked in a bay probably one
that doesn't exist anymore and he left
the ship walked onto the peninsula and
carried with him a journal and in that
journal he began to keep copious notes
and fortunately for me a lot of those
notes were about the natural world he
saw around him when he stepped onto the
peninsula he wrote the plane is by no
means a dead flat but of uneven surface
the soil is of a sandy nature and was
wholly under pasture on which were
grazing several flocks of sheep and
herds of cattle the sides of the
surrounding hills though but moderately
elevated seemed barren and their summits
were composed of naked uneven rocks two
small spaces in the plain were
appropriated to kitchen Gardens the
several seeds once planted in the ground
nature was left to do the rest without
receiving any assistance for manual
labor
the nature that Vancouver was describing
had already been radically transformed
by humans even in 1792 more recently by
the Spanish missionaries and then four
millennia before that by the Native
Americans and again a lot of those
changes were physical and a lot of those
changes were ideas that became imprinted
in that rock record and I'll speak only
for myself you know if you've heard
talks about these ideas of restoration
biology or de-extinction the idea of
bringing extinct animals back to life at
the heart of these ideas so that we can
somehow return nature to a state a
pristine state before humans and
speaking only for myself I'll say it's
enticing it's very easy to become
nostalgic for this idea of a pristine
nature or pristine wilderness but as
we've seen through just tens of
thousands of years here that's also a
nature that never really existed
there is no pristine it's constantly
changing
there is no baseline but that doesn't
mean that these layers disappear if they
did I would have had a really hard time
putting this talk together when we read
the rocks of San Francisco were not just
reading our natural history but we're
seeing how the natural world and our
relationship with the natural world has
informed our culture we've seen Gold
bring commerce we've seen the bay and
the harbor bring trade in the exchange
of ideas and we've seen the food
bringing pretentious Yelp reviews when
you know where to look for it you can
find this amazing amalgam of our
personal history and our natural history
written into our rocks thank you
[Applause]
thank you so everyone gets your
questions in mind Rio Rio hold up your
hand hold up the mic there's a
microphone in the back with Rio and Rio
we'll look for her and she will find you
with the mic and then I'll find her
to get your question up up here we've
got a lot of questions I think for here
and and I also again want to mention the
folks on the live stream I understand
we've got folks from as far as Michigan
and Oregon tonight thanks for for tuning
in folks and you guys can add questions
to just put them in the chat and I'll
actually be able to see them up here on
stage so miles your suit so you wrote me
in an email or talking about what what
it is you do for a living because
believe it or not this is not the only
thing he does and you said deceased
seafloor landscapes and their
interactions with fluid mechanic
mechanics processes is that is that
about right can can you do a slight
translation of that for us absolutely so
it turns out and actually there's a
great picture with auto right up here
that helps demonstrate this it turns out
that we have way way better pictures of
the surface of Mars than we do of our
own sea floor and our sea floor is
remarkable it's an absolutely alien
environment there are a lot of things
happening down there that are very
difficult to explain and a lot of things
that in my opinion are quite beautiful
and we have a lot of impact on turns out
so if you remember when I was talking
about ancient sea level rise in the
river that cut across the slope when sea
level was way out past the Farallon or
when the shoreline was out past the
farallon's well you can see at contour
number two it does this sort of weird
pointy thing pointing back in towards
the bay and that little pointy thing is
actually a canyon that's been carved
into the slope in the submarine floor
and those are the types of things that
I'm really interested in because one
they're huge
if you go down to Monterey Bay there's a
canyon out there that's bigger than the
Grand Canyon and - we have no idea how
they form and I like answering those
kinds of problems cuz no one can argue
with me I say it does this sure but the
cool thing from a human perspective in
dealing with this is that one day
actually the flows that we think create
these pose huge problems to man-made
infrastructure as things like Telegraph
cables and Internet cables and things
like that that run along the seafloor
and the second thing is that a lot of
the stuff that we end up dumping into
the rivers and the stuff that we use for
agriculture will end up hundreds of
miles offshore out in these deposits
they're carried through these submarine
canyons and so actually if you really
want to record a really accurate signal
of the Anthropocene I argue that going
out to these deep-sea fans and getting a
core out through there is one of the
best ways to do that and how would
characterize for us because obviously
you're here you you know this area
really well it seems like a
fantastically interesting geologic area
give us a sense of I mean these are we
uniquely like that or is everywhere as
interesting as this or and I'm kind of
what's sort of where where would you
rank the the Bay Area geology oh no and
so many people that's that's our goal
here reputation yeah they're gonna
alienate the room or the rest of the
world I will say that California and
specifically the Bay Area geology is
among the most complex that we know of
and it's very strange because there have
been a lot of different things that have
happened here a lot that I've mentioned
in the talk and one of the weirdest
things that happen that I didn't get a
chance to talk about is that the Pacific
plate and the North American plate used
to be doing this and now they're doing
this that's weird and it's also a
process that we don't really know all
that much about and so there there's a
lot of weirdness that sort of built into
the
geology around here and in terms of a
human impact in the rock record it works
very well here because of a lot of the
agriculture because of the water because
of the bay because we have a lot of
things that settle very slowly and give
us very clean layers to help us
demarcate sort of geologic time so I do
think the bay area is sort of unique in
that sense but all geology is awesome
you can go to some really cool places
and just have one rock type I'll do a
quick aside so there's a weird rock type
formation that's actually in Central
Texas and in Central Texas most of the
rocks that are there are all in the
order of you know maybe tens of millions
of years old the oldest you get is maybe
150 million years old something like
that and then there's just this one
sprig or rock out in the middle and
nowhere that's like six hundred and
fifty million years old
sure whereabouts is whereabouts is that
it's just I think it's just west of
central Texas I don't know exactly where
what city it's near because I'm pretty
sure it's out in the middle of nowhere
but it is it's one of those really weird
problems that people been trying to
figure out for quite some time I think
we got a question back there
thank you for awesome description of how
gold forms that I've always been curious
and I'm wondering if you've come across
this California it seems to be one of
the only places in the world where huge
chunks of gold sat upon the surface with
people walking by them for at least
10,000 years and nobody cared about them
everywhere else in the whole world and
and it's at least that I know of people
really really cared about it and it
became this precious object and I'm
wondering if you know of other places
where that was the case or if you've
heard of any reasons why the California
Native Americans decided they didn't
care about gold i off the top of my head
the closest analogy that I would have to
Gold just being out in the open that
people tend to just to not care that
much about would actually be in the
Dakota Territory and the Native
Americans in the Dakota Territory 'he's
also saw the gold and didn't care that
much about it until it was discovered by
I believe soldiers but don't quote me
that bit of history and when gold was
discovered you know the phrase there's
gold in them thar hills that was what
that was referring to was the Black
Hills and all of a sudden something like
oh you know the city for those of you
who are fans of HBO's Deadwood you know
the city of Deadwood went from having a
population of about maybe like 5,000 to
a population of 40,000 in like two years
and that was just everyone going gold oh
my god there's gold and that was where
that gold rush sort of began but I would
guess that actually that idea of gold
being precious is only a new thing my
hunch is that for most of human history
gold would be oh that's pretty but I
can't eat that that's right yeah and I
don't I don't know when it became
something of this is a precious object
this is something that means a lot to us
too I am willing to murder everyone to
obtain that object I'm sure there's
somebody out there who knows the answer
to that I'm not that person
right there can you talk a bit about how
climate change is affecting geologic
science sure so we're gonna be here for
a while so yeah exactly that's a whole
other talk but let me go through a
couple of the quick versions of it one
of the big ones is that climate change
is affecting agriculture hugely and in
order to make up for the warmer
temperatures and the increased droughts
we're finding ourselves dumping more and
more fertilizers and those fertilizers
end up in groundwater they end up in
surface runoff they end up in rivers and
then they end up depositing out in the
oceans and so you get these huge
chemical signatures and that's one way
that climate change is affecting the
hardrock sort of geology another big way
is through ocean acidification as carbon
dioxide goes up into the air a lot of
that gets absorbed by sea water when you
take carbon dioxide and dissolve it and
sea water it becomes carbonic acid and
that acid begins to eat away at coral
reefs and those reefs disappear from the
rock record they're called reef gaps and
we've seen them at various times in
Earth history and we're almost certainly
going to
see that in the near future so that's
another sort of very tangible way that
we're gonna see climate change affecting
the rock record then there's some other
weirder ways that I won't dive super
into because it involves a lot of
geochemistry that gets again there'd be
a whole other talk to sort of go through
that but with climate change there's a
natural cycle to how carbon is released
and reabsorbed by the planet and climate
change is messing with that largely
through what's called weathering
chemical weathering and it's basically
just a fancy way of saying rain falls on
rock the rock changes its chemical shape
and as a result of undergoing a chemical
change it absorbs carbon dioxide or
releases carbon dioxide and those signal
signals are changing so there's a couple
of different ways that climate change is
actually affecting the hard rock sort of
history of the planet right now in the
bay area there are the clearest signal
is going to be the agricultural signal
and you've seen that in the last couple
of years until very recently when El
Nino came in and helped us didn't make
everything better but El Nino certainly
helped us get through this huge extended
period of drought and that drought is
something that you can read not only in
the rock record and you see the layers
of changing thickness of rock but you
can also see that in tree rings you can
see how the trees will change their
growth rates and those trees will also
get preserved sometimes if we're lucky
in the rock record and and I should say
quickly that because I think we'll have
more questions than you could answer but
then you have more answers than we can
question so miles is gonna stick around
so please do stick around also and
continue to ask him questions a quick
follow-up on that question can you say
something about how scientists and
different disciplines are collaborating
because obviously geology is the best
but you know their their effects on
biology they're their effects on animals
and and and plant systems can you say
something about how say the data you're
doing gets used what other scientists
are collaborating with you especially on
the climate change side sure so
yeah the sort of name of the game this
happened a little bit in the late 1990s
early 2000s there was a major shift in
earth sciences and it stopped being I'm
a geologist on the biologist I'm a
geophysicist that stopped really being a
thing and what shifted was this idea
that became known as an earth systems
approach and earth systems means
basically what it sounds like the idea
that geology is separate from biology
why it's just not true and so it
involved building way more complicated
models which was fortunate because now
we had way more powerful computers to
start dealing with those kinds of
problems and so a very micro example
that's also kind of I think a humorous
example of people collaborating across a
lot of different disciplines in
landscape evolution there are a lot of
models for how landscapes will evolve
how erosion basically occurs and it used
to be we would look at things like
rainfall rivers done and that was kind
of what we would look at and now when
you have those same models it's not just
the sort of physical processes the
physics based stuff but there's also
equations where the terms in the
equation are I kid you not humans and
Gophers because it turns out Gophers can
dig up so much material that they
themselves will transform landscape and
that's a biological reveal that we never
would have thrown into a geological
model before but these are some examples
of whether that collaboration work of
ferrocene I don't think they're that
dominant maybe I don't know we have
another question over here there we go
he mentioned the when the California
Valley was being formed that was
scraping off the top layer of another
plate which PVC had been under what you
called a shallow ocean that's right how
shallow was a shallow
compared to but I would think of is like
the Pacific Ocean today and why was that
shallower than other oceans okay once
again this is like a whole talk but
we'll go through it briefly
so short version the depth of the ocean
is in large part dependent on the
density of the crust and so because
basalt which is what ocean crust is made
of is very dense and granite actually
isn't granite is pretty buoyant and
granite is basically what most
continents are made out of the
continents tend to rise up and the
basalt tends to sink down and that's
what will create the topography
difference that eventually becomes the
ocean depth so that's basic oceans 101
but it gets more complicated than that
so the reason it was buried under a
shallow ocean and not a deep ocean is
because there's a shelf that runs out
along the coastline in fact that one
contour line there that's basically
where the continental shelf is and that
the location of that line is again
largely dependent on the chemical
composition the actual mineral
composition of the crust whether it's
all basalt or all granite spoiler alert
there's really no such thing as all of
any one type of rock but it so usually
some sort of a difference and so you'll
eventually find this place where the
crust is like I can be buoyant I can be
boy no I can't and it falls off and that
I mean I'm grossly oversimplifying this
but that's basically where that line
shows up and so what ends up happening
is that you have this buoyant crust over
here this dense crust over here and then
you have sort of a shallow depth you
know a shallow falling off and then a
steep drop-off and then it just falls
flat because the the most of the planet
is made up of this basalt that just sits
way way low down and to create the deep
ocean so that's where the shallow ocean
comes from and it wasn't all one depth
that was gradually getting deeper as you
moved to the west but it was still much
shallower than you know the Marianas
Trench is way way way WAY WAY deeper
than what was there can't believe you
ruined that basalt thing for everybody
that's I'm that guy now and and and as I
said you'll be able to talk about more
things afterwards but I want to get in
quickly before you another audience
question the game of Thrones
the Game of Thrones thing now this was
something that just came straight out of
your head right there is is that right
you just tell us tell us how the light
bulb went off or or how you got obsessed
with this so the short version is that
using my knowledge of geology and
geological history I was able to go
through the Game of Thrones books the TV
show and I'll say too many other
websites to build a five hundred million
year plus geological history of the game
of Thrones planet which you can see in
that colorful map in the middle there
and the the project began with me
sitting out with a friend of mine and
we're big pop culture fans were big Game
of Thrones fans and he's a climate
scientist my friends a climate scientist
and he was wandering about how in the
game of Thrones universe seasons make no
sense like all of a sudden it's winter
for two years and then it's summer for
three months and then it's winter for
two weeks and then it's summer for five
years and it just made no sense and
there been a lot of people have actually
run like physical models physics based
models try to figure out how this works
short answer it doesn't and so my
friends I patha --ss was wait a minute
fire burning stuff changes climate fire
can change climate rapidly what if it
was dragons fire that was changing the
climate really quickly and rather than
laugh I thought I could calculate that
[Applause]
that's what I came from and so their
plot twist that you're getting like in
the weather patterns that we're not even
appreciated totally yeah also also
there's a really fun moment for those
who are Game of Thrones aficionados and
you if you're not if you just want to
dive into the geology I go through and
explain sort of like similar to this
contour by contour geologic just a blog
post right you've got a bunch of pages
it's a great read and you can you can
sort of dive into all of this history
and one of the the the things that was
really interesting is that I was trying
my best to make things work and they
worked surprisingly well like that was
the shocking part to me and I finished
it I was like good here it is and I put
it out and then another friend of mine
who's also a climate scientist was like
wait a minute wait a minute when did you
say the last big Ice Age was and I went
through my calculations and he went okay
and what are the elevations of those
mountains I said here are the elevations
those mountains and he was like okay
okay wait and what's the size and I was
like do what are you doing he's like mom
I'm plugging them into my model right
now and he actually was going through to
see if the rise of these mountains that
I had timed interest in a geological
background would match the climate
patterns and spoiler alert they matched
and I was like wow that's awesome so it
turns out science works
science science you got a question up
front here just hold it close you'll be
good like Barry right okay so my first
question is and I know the answer is it
depends but on average just how thick is
the Earth's crust that's floating above
the mantle and then the second question
is what effect does that have on plate
tectonics and movement and you know for
instance like why no super big-ass
earthquakes in the Himalayas you get
what I'm saying
totally once again is the answer
triology the answer is of course geology
alright great I have you all queued up
now this is awesome so you're right the
answer is of course it depends but
weirdly it only really depends if you're
on a continent or if you're on the ocean
most ocean crust tends to be about the
same thickness and this is where I'm
going to enrage certain geologists
because the crust is actually it's a
hard term to define it's a little bit
like saying planet you know the idea
that earth and Jupiter are somehow in
the same class just doesn't make a lot
of sense and the crust of Earth there's
not like there it is
there's the bottom it's actually much
more difficult to define than that but
generally speaking oceanic crust is
about maybe ten miles thick give or take
and the under a continent it can be 30
ish 35 miles thick and again I'm in
raging certain geologists gonna be like
oh my god those numbers are way too
small but generally speaking that's
about what it is and so in terms of
plate motions and how that works into
plate tectonics again this goes this is
primarily actually density driven so
because you have basalt which is that
ocean crust it's much thinner so you get
this up mantle upwelling and mantle is
very very hot and especially the stuff
that's coming up from deeper the deeper
you go the hotter it gets and so as it
comes up to the surface it hits the
crust and it wants to keep going but it
can't go up any more so it starts to go
in different directions right convection
cells and so the it basically creates a
conveyor belt and with the basalt which
is much denser begins to get basically
translated over on this conveyor belt
and it hits the continental crust and
then goes like oh crap well I can't go
any farther
well I'm denser than the other one so it
drops down and it starts to sink down
underneath it cuz it's much colder at
this point and so it begins to fall
under under under and then it melts and
as it melts it a lot of the water boils
off and creates a lot of volatility noes
come from that's where they get the Ring
of Fire around the Pacific Ocean but
that it's not so much the thickness that
helps drive the plate motions it's the
density differences in between them and
then the reasons that you get really big
earthquakes
some reason in some regions and not in
others is if you imagine that the crust
is only this thick and we'll just say
that it's ten miles thick and if you
draw a fault through it that's straight
vertical you don't have a lot of surface
area but if you cut it at a really
shallow angle you now have a lot of
surface area and so you can build up a
lot of friction
well those shallow subduction areas
don't exist everywhere in the world and
you can get big earthquakes on steeply
dipping faults but the really really big
earthquakes the ones that in 2001
created the huge tsunami in Sumatra
Japan the mega earthquake that happened
there those happen because of a
combination of things one because there
was a lot of surface area to hold on to
that friction and the second is that
those plates are hauling ass
geologically speaking I mean this is
yeah look when I hear someone put that
on Twitter please oh my god so that's
where they go quick follow up on that do
we know do we understand what all the
plates are where those are we deducing
based on previous seismic activity or do
we actually know all the places that
have that type of configuration that
potential um
we know the configurations for the big
earthquakes for the most part one of the
reasons that the the Tohoku earthquake
was such a big surprise the one that
happened in Japan
it was such a big surprise because all
of the models that have been applied
previously turned out to be wrong
and they'd suggested that fault or the
strain on that fault couldn't build up
in the way that it did and that was just
turns out to be wrong observations
people were interpreting the
observations incorrectly it's more
appropriate way of saying that so we
know those plate configurations
reasonably well with where those big
earthquakes are gonna happen but one of
the most interesting questions that's
hidden in what you just asked is do we
know where all of the plate boundaries
are and the answer is no one of the most
interesting things that's happening
right now at least interesting to me
me personally is there's an area in
Eastern Africa it's called the East
African Rift and it runs a lot through
Kenya and caught the african continent's
actually starting back sort of split
apart and there's debate and I wouldn't
say it's healthy debate but there is
some level of debate if we're watching
the birth of a new tectonic plate there
would be no precedent for this we've
never seen it on human time scales
because tectonics takes a really long
time to work but that might be a
boundary that we're still trying to
figure out a little bit there's a lot of
micro tectonics in the West Pacific that
don't make a lot of sense but we have a
fairly good idea but the great mystery
right now if you're looking for a
fundamental problem in geology if you
want to dive into it where the plate
boundaries in the Arctic we have no idea
in fact the motions of the plates when
we get up that far are really difficult
to constrain one because GPS satellites
tend not to orbit the Arctic so you
can't get really really accurate
measurements but also because it's all
ice floe I'm gonna set up a GPS station
I'm gonna set up a GPS I'm gonna set up
it just keeps drifting and so you can't
actually make a good measurement and so
it's very very difficult to figure out
how things are moving and then also you
have the huge ice sheet which is melting
rapidly so maybe we'll be able to figure
it out soon and you can actually go down
and see a little bit more like image the
seafloor and try to figure out where
exactly the plate boundaries are
sneaking around up there so so so we're
about to wrap up and like I said he's
gonna stick around some key words to ask
him about are what was the time period
when all the fossil fuels arrived which
is pretty much yeah so that's one thing
super here at the carbon footprint of
super-heroes more about Game of Thrones
or lots of things to ask him to please
stay around and do that I have one last
question and and as I said we're right
up at the end so so this is fun this is
a great talk it's really fun we've all
learned a lot we've been entertained say
something for a second about what's
important about connecting science to
pop culture being entertaining about it
I don't know I mean because obviously
you enjoy this and it's your nerdery
that
you're following around to your nerd
instincts to do it yeah but is it is it
important to scientists to other
scientists is it helping to make things
happen can you just say something about
cuz obviously it's part of your approach
to science sure I'm biased but yeah of
course it's important it's important for
a lot of different reasons science is as
for too long been portrayed is something
that only sits in this this lofty realm
of of experts sitting you know up in the
clouds doing things that we can't
possibly do and that's crap we can all
do this it takes a lot of time and it
takes you have to learn a lot you have
to stick with it you have to have a lot
of perseverance and through that process
of learning a lot of these materials you
find different ways of teaching it of
making it interesting of making it
engaging and that's where it's really
important and I will argue for even
fellow scientists to sort of show how to
make their work more approachable to the
rest of the world it was one of the
things that inspired the carbon
footprint of super-heroes project is
that you know climate change is
unquestionably one of the biggest
problems that we've ever faced and yet
here's a room of very intelligent people
if I asked all of you if I said my
carbon footprint is 44,000 pounds per
year is that number good or bad exactly
like it's a hard question like and we
hear these ideas and we have these
numbers in these concepts but they don't
mean anything to us at a really deep
sort of level but when you can attach
that does something that people already
have maybe too much meaning in like a
game of Thrones or superheroes speaking
only for myself I've invested a lot in
these two worlds but when you invest
when you bring more meaning to that that
makes people you know makes it much
easier for people to draw the parallels
in their own lives that's that's at the
heart of these projects and that's why I
think you have to be entertaining you
have to try to link this stuff to
popular culture and the
things that we experience in our
everyday lives much more frequently
however you know we want to say that's
good or bad that's just what's true we
experience these things way more
frequently than we do a geology textbook
or a lesson of the 1906 earthquake so
that's why it's important
miles ready
[Applause]
[Music]